Alexandr change ass how do you meet
relevant people at South by Southwest
you know Alexander I think the first
opening move is to get out of the
mentality of douchery that justifies and
categorizes people that did he seem
relevant I believe so
did he that he I wanna make sure I'm
using the right word it was relevant
Alex honestly that I don't know like if
I could execute what was happening in my
stomach right now when I hear people
categorize other human beings as
relevant it makes me want to vomit on
myself but I don't think you're a bad
guy Alexander III I think I think you're
asking a proper question I would say
first of all relevancy is massively
subjective right like there's people
that have a lot of followers that have
influence that are VCS that whatever
you're looking for I would tell you I
promise you that if it again I think
you're seeing a theme in my talk guys
I'm a very big fan of the second chess
move in life if you're just trying to
get to this person everybody's trying to
get to this relevant [ __ ] person and
so what happens is it becomes a supply
and demand issue where you're getting
pounded on you're not breaking through
because they're defending against the
supply but when Alex when you open
yourself up to meeting somebody who
might not be a relevant person by your
definition there are a shitload of
people running around at South by
Southwest then if you have a drink with
and say hello or the exact person that's
the gateway to 30 minutes of my time at
South by Southwest but on paper with
their 306 Twitter followers it's not
gonna seem so obvious I promise when you
stop strategizing people's [ __ ] Klout
and you start acting like a human being
you will win